[Musique]
bonjour alain bonjour france passe alors
tu as le soleil et l'ascendant dans un
signe des gémeaux et les jeux soleil l
ascendant et la sono vous êtes et
l'ascendant et l'ascendant en disant que
le signe des gémeaux et on signe
dominant de loin et que c'est un signe
comme tu sais d'ouverture de mobilité de
vivacité je dirais en un mot donc de
jeunesse ça c est ce que tu as toujours
disant intérieurement
alors non non non non non non non non le
temps passe on à moi je trouve qu'on a
une vie artistique en qui passent comme
comme l'eau de vie mais plus vite quoi
c'était lui ont fait des albums et puis
au fur et à mesure que le temps passe et
ben on devient adulte dans l'écriture
dans la façon de chanter dans le truc et
puis on vieillit après on doit faire des
mauvais album de vieux cons radotant et
une vie assez vaut plus courte mais une
vie artistique plus court comme la vie
humaine mais en plus quand raccourci est
ce que tu te sens davantage le fils de
ta femme est le frère de tes enfants que
le mari de la femme et le faire de tes
enfants
c'est un test oh ben non je me sens pas
le je me sens pas le faire de mes
enfants du tout est le fils de ma femme
non plus on est tous de tous les hommes
évidemment ils doivent dans la femme
qu'ils aiment ils doivent rechercher un
peu n'ont pas tous la salue les gémeaux
qui fuit un petit peu les
responsabilités quand même qu'ils sont
plus copains avec leurs enfants que
véritablement à nos responsables adultes
tous et pour tout tester simplement pour
six adultes que tu le prétend c'est à
dire je fais des efforts voilà je ne me
laisse pas complètement aller
bon alors je trouve qu elle veut des
enfants c'est vachement difficile ouais
je dis ça sérieusement c'est vrai on
constate souvent que les gens naissent
ou ceci les vieillissent quand même
moins moins rapidement extérieur -
visiblement que des tas d'autres gens
alors bon je trouve que c'est le cas
pour toi quand même mon petit 1 1 pour
se jeter des fleurs aussi passionnés
parmi eux d'une bouche pendant
lesquelles j'étais bête 1-0 et mais
simplement je voulais te demander ce qui
tombe était le plus dans le fait de
veiller en dehors des cheveux dans la
baignoire
surtout quand tu as la sensation que le
temps passe quoi et donc que tu vas
mourir et puis que c'est ça qui est
pénible
il ya une légèreté dans la jeunesse où
on se rend pas compte qu'on va mauvais
ce qui est merveilleux quoi restons avec
les jets moore qui prédisposent quand
même avoir du mal à ne s'intéresser qu'à
une seule personne en même temps et je
fais un raccourci là ce que tu aurais m
insultant ce ne devrait plus être assis
d'avoir plein de femmes rêvent
ça doit être marrant comme ça où démarre
place ouais mais c'est pas pareil les
sultans à l heure des lois ça va la
ferme est elle la ferme non mais c'est
sous ce nom mais pas de façon classique
qu'est ce que tu fais quand quand il
sent qu une attirance risque de temps
mais un petit peu trop loin pour toi tu
vois mon nom je me laisse attirer n'ya
pas de feux rouges que dès que les feux
verts moi je suis avec la même personne
je parle jamais de ces choses là tu sais
toi qui m'oblige m'enfin on se connaît
depuis longtemps je dis ça je suis avec
la même personne depuis longtemps et ça
me convient parfaitement comme ça c'est
parce que j'aime bien que ça dure c'est
parce que c'était fait pour être comme
ça quoi c'est vraiment un plaisir tout
le temps alors voilà évidemment les gens
qui nous écoutent à savent pas c'est que
tu as un ciel dans lequel toutes les
planètes sont valorisés ce qui veut dire
que en plus des gémeaux qui prédisposent
d'ores et déjà à être non pas d'où mes
multiples il ya des tas de tendance qui
devrait et coexister en toi tu es plus
pluriel que que singulier ça m'est très
difficile pour moi de faire mon boulot
normalement tout ça quand je fais des
interviews et tout ça me pompe
énormément et je dis des conneries
contradictoires tout le temps parce que
je trouve que j'ai toujours un avis
contraire
je ne sais pas c'était peut-être que
c'est une folie où tu me dises que vous
aimeriez mieux vivre à la campagne à la
ville pour moi ça va être un dilemme de
terry pas ce que je vais te dire non
j'aime beaucoup le stress de la ville et
machin mais évidemment ça me rend fou et
j'ai envie de vivre à la campagne
voilà j'ai tout le temps le contraire
quoi le truc et puis le contraire j'aime
bien alors ce n'est aucun sens de dire
ça on peut pas être le truc et puis le
contraire qui en fait si est-ce que tu
t'ennuies facilement tu as écrit une
chanson sur l'année mais j'ai oublié
excusé mais cela n'a pas marché du jour
je fais des chansons parce que je
m'ennuie si je m'ennuie pas si j'ai une
vieille fille
je viens comme ça te parler ensuite
demain je vais faire une interview
ensuite je fais une télé des machins
tout ce que je peux pas écrire des
chansons
il faut que après je me retire et puis
je m'en vais à la campagne ou dans un
endroit isolé pour écrire j arrive pas
et il est arrivé un moment où vraiment
je m'emmerde quoi et l'ennui ça fait que
ça fait que j'avais envie d'écrire des
chances tout ça ça ça trahit ça traduit
au fond une difficulté sentir concernés
c'est comme ça j'arrive pas être
vraiment par exemple le mot passion me
dégoûte les gens qui ont des passions du
jeu de boules ou qui ont des passions de
l'eau des boîtes d'allumettes ou bien
deux ou même de l'asie où vous êtes
aussi pour quelqu'un c'est aussi la
passion à webo non non mais mettons à
part ça à paris s'associe à part ça je
te parle le mot passion qui est galvaudé
qu'on voit partout la passion de ceux ci
la passion de cela la passion voillemot
patients partout c'est répugnant
alors moi j'ai pas ça je n'arrive pas à
être passionné de musique j'aime
beaucoup la musique j'en écoute depuis
toujours et puis j'en ai coûterait sans
doute toujours mais je ne peux pas dire
que si j'ai pas de musique pendant
quinze jours je vais être malade ou
c'est pas une passion dévorante et tu
regrettes ne pas avoir le jeu regrette
de préparation oui oui oui je vois les
gens ils sont entre autres ebace a fait
passer la pilule est une passion cet
aveugle des passifs et là avec tanks et
boîtes de nuit mais où sont les boîtes
d'allumettes je vais avoir une autre
boîte d'allumettes comme mesure dope
dans ma collection de boîtes
d'allumettes
est ce que tu penses pas que par moment
tu manques un petit peu de rigueur un
petit peu de sélectivité en ce qui
compte en ce qui concerne le choix de
tes musiques
c'est intelligent fait pas mal donc déjà
studieux mais je traversais la codah
bonnemaison payton
et je parle surtout pour les deux
dernières les deux derniers albums
quand moi je fais juste le nombre de
chansons qu'il faut pour faire des
albums et puis si et puisse donc ça veut
dire que c'est pas tellement un choix
quoi ce moment c'est pas tellement je
suis pas tellement un choix ou alors
quand tu fais un air évidemment tu
choisis parmi les notes ce qu'ils
deviennent ou bien celles qui viennent à
ton copain mais que tu écoutes en même
temps tu es tu lui donnes l'approbation
tout de suite ou pas mais si c'est comme
ça c'est que ça doit pas être autrement
je veux dire être autrement moi je
trouve par exemple
non mais j'ai dit pas autre chose quand
même le dis comme ça oui et non mais non
tu travailles très souvent avec laurent
voulzy du monde le sait et je trouve que
les mélodies je sais bien que vous ne
faites pas exactement le même genre de
chanson et qu'il faut que les style
mélodique soit différent mais je trouve
que quand même les mélodies que laurent
compose pour lui sont d'une force et
d'une efficacité qu'on ne trouve pas
dans les mélodies qui composent pour toi
et je me demande si là tu devrais pas
être un petit peu plus exigeants
vis-à-vis des eaux non non non si ça
vient de toi aussi ça vienne lui
finement de même peut-être que les
textes que je lui fais ils sont plus
légers plus percutant le soleil donne
c'est plus efficace et plus commerciale
que ultra moderne solitude que je fais
pour moi parce que c'est comme ça ça
peut pas être autrement
les mélodies qui fait au moment où il
est fait je dis ça ça me convient c'est
moi qui choisis c'est parce que j'ai
mauvais goût françois non mais c'est
vrai parfois quand même attention
[Musique]